okay so today continuing out of
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics
- last class what are we talk about
Kentucky was the nature of happiness and
what the good ones yeah and we had this
term that came up over and over again
virtually right and a lot of other
things came up as candidates for
happiness and those arts waffle things
you know pursuing well does that make
you a bad person
no you actually need some well you need
some property you're from ourselves
perspective you're actually going to
have a hard time being a good person if
you're dirt no heart attacks to you if
you're very rich because you'll do
something to more temptations but you
actually need to have some news
what about public with your life be a
life devoted to duty and you know
depriving yourself of pleasures so that
you can you know concentrate just on
that no you know a good life is a
pleasant life and we can talk about
different kinds of pleasures we'll do
that before I'm going to look at book
seven you know there's some funders that
probably we shouldn't have told you
like you know heroin heroin or pleasure
to open yourself into that one done
pretty much everything else I'm gonna
take a back seat but there's a lot of
pleasures that are really worth water
and some that Aristotle would want you
to cultivate the pleasure of that that
comes with doing good actions he wants
that that's a good thing health health
is a important condition to even honor
or respect those are important things
relationships are but ultimately for
Aristotle what's going to
Herman this is a question of what makes
something good or bad is going to be a
virtue and vice so that's what we're
going to look at today the nature of
which it was before that I want to do a
little bit of preparatory work so almost
all of you have no paper out I'd like
you to write down some of the answers to
these questions I'd like you to think
about one thing that you're good
everybody here is a good at something
and you know could be something that's
trivial
you're really good at arranging things
on a desk you know people look at your
your your desk and they say pilots are
very tiny orderly desk I'm betting that
all of you are good at something way
beyond that something more important and
in scope some of you might be Musical or
artistic some of you may be something or
intellectual or some of you it may be
something physical or tied in with your
emotions but I want you to think of one
thing that you're you're good at and
then I want you to think of that and you
probably will have to think about this
how did you actually get good when you
mainly have some native talent probably
it did because we like to do things that
were we're already a little bit good at
all right then we tend I'm not good at
that I'm going to leave that for so long
time but that's not all in it so think
about how you actually got good if
you're still good at how do you actually
maintain your level of skill and
expertise or goodness and then I want
you to think about this let's say you
actually did that something to be a
talent and you cultivated it how would
you take somebody else who doesn't have
and make them
so I want you to I'm gonna bring this up
a little late that's where as we're
going through this I want you to think
about these these things that I'm going
to ask you about that or the use of
those examples in class so they have to
make a McCain both nickel became that
textbook to you notice that with this
kind of schema and a big question what
makes the action is what makes an action
that's one of the things we talked about
that things something you do or don't do
but also for Aristotle and emotional
response there are subtle things that
you can be too angry or not angry enough
or that your desires can be too strong
or too weak or that you can feel joy or
sadness or pain or pleasure for the
right reasons or for the wrong reasons
we can evaluate our emotions this is
something that's really foreign to a lot
of people in our culture were often told
we often distinguish between our actions
and our emotions and we always tell
people yeah it's okay to how you feel
you know just don't act up if you have
done them all will judge you
we don't judge your feelings but I've
heard about things you actually can
judge people's currents because you know
it is possible to go wrong with the
weight of your field not all feelings
are actually well fast or good responses
some feelings are in fact harmful or
unhealthy or ugly or damaging to people
yes you know if you're angry this is why
he talks about the virtue of good temper
if you find yourself all the time going
off the court you know over little
things there's something wrong if you
find yourself getting angry and then not
being able to let it go
and having to do something to the other
person before you can feel okay there's
a problem there and you have lost
respect feelings well your feelings can
be good or bad and we'll talk more about
this when we get to the actual
discussions of the virtues in the books
the three and four and five which is
going to come back to it and then
there's patterns of behavior right
we not only feel the the term that
you're going to tour though that your
taxes is the passion right the actions
and passions passions means feelings
emotions means designers emotional
responses that you have patterns larger
patterns of behavior would you trust
your money to adjust anything rather
there's some people that you know they
should not trust the play yes or no
probably everyone I know some of you
should write to the family member to be
a friend to the former friend because it
trusted him with money
what is it just their action single
action that determines whether they're
trustworthy or not I mean there could be
want something that somebody does it
totally destroys your trust right like
like for instance they they now they
don't pay it back then use that money to
steal your boyfriend and girlfriend from
you taking them out on a date that's
pretty bad state threads with somebody
like that you need to the same support
Academy sorry but it's more
automatically you know the way a person
is by how they act over time so it's not
just you know the person once you get
once or they'll pay back once it's that
they do this consistently right how do
you know that's a matter of justice pain
so it's bad right how do you know who
would have your back in the fight do you
know that just by talking to somebody a
little bit you know that's a virtue
that's courage it could also be a button
so they could be the kind of person who
gets in fights all the time
would actually pull you into a fight
that's not that's not what you got
supply success that's that's from
rafters but how do we know somebody is
going to actually back you up when
things get tough doesn't that
necessarily have to be a fight could be
a meeting where they have to stand up to
somebody who's kind of scary could be
you have a problem with a professor and
you have to go in and talk with that
professor who's rooting you around and
your friend is going to come along with
you some of your friends might sell you
out when they get there right they might
turn around and walk out you don't want
that friend together now how do you know
that that person is going to act that
way do you know that from just one
circumstance
nobody's know they're from patterns of
behavior we you know we're creatures of
habit the way that we are our characters
are largely dr. Singhal actions or
emotions their patterns that we so how
do we actually tell what's good in most
animals so look at all these different
things we have the consequences we have
the desires or the intention you can
look at the basic kind of action or
emotional response just you're getting
angry you know you can look at the
reasoning that's involved why somebody's
doing what they're doing that's a sort
of like intention to service time and
you can look at the person who is doing
the action themselves now everybody has
to vote how many of you in here think
that what matters the most is
now suppose it's our dryer
nobody here thinks that the consequences
are the most important thing you're
always welcome Oh mr. - it's on there
are some moral theories that think their
consequences are the most important
thing we're going to study them you know
think about through silicates what was
the consequence really having power
anything that would get you power that
was a good thing but you don't have to
be kind of a bad guy
just to see that you could say anything
that promotes human welfare that's a
good thing if you're an action for
vulture it's good whatabout your desires
are your intention when you when you
we're trying to do what you what you
were aiming who thinks that that's okay
you guys are probably going to be more
attracted to comment although you're
going to find a lot in Aristotle when we
look at them and their desires are your
attention are very important you know
one can do an action that has good
consequences and do it you know totally
wrong reason I might teach you Aristotle
well not because I care about your
development of students which would be a
good attention but because I want to get
good student ratings which is probably a
period of mutual intention but it's not
really the best reason why I shouldn't
teach them all right I could let's take
one
I could tell somebody at a bar that they
are beautiful in order to raise their
self-esteem on a day when everybody has
been beating them down it's a good
attention and same consequence they feel
better about themselves or I might do it
just to get them in Dell let's make it
even worse you know so I can get them
into bed and black men take incriminated
photographs that's a very different
intention isn't it so those of you that
think intention man lose your you're
onto something
so the things that's the basic type of
the action you can look at certain
actions and say this kind of action was
good at this pantry actions man nobody
everybody has to fall this is part of
class participation what about the
reason the thinking our God you know how
things go okay again you guys will
probably find comes to be somebody that
you also to certain Senator John Street
one but also Harris mom what about the
person the person doing
there's quickly understood a couple
different ways maybe there's there's
some things that we let people get away
with because who they are because
they're rich well so that's okay for
them or you know here's that serious
something that gets thrown around years
ago there used to be a lot more debate
in philosophy classes and you know
campuses about abortion and how people
are able to in camps and the most part
pretty firmly decide that I'm on this
side and on this side there's to be a
lot more public discourse about it and
one of the things we hear sometimes I
suppose it was the main that was you
can't say anything about it because you
can't possibly have an abortion
so that safety would be it would be bad
it would be wrong for you to to say
anything about it based on who you are
it would be right for a woman to talk
about it would be wrong for a man to
talk about it one of the very early
legal codes you guys would all remember
back in Western Civ the Code of
Hammurabi you know beginning of legal
codes and all that it actually had
different penalties for crimes depending
on treated did the crime too so if you
did the crime to dissuade it not so much
of a penalty if you did the crime to a
free person by your penalty if you did
it to an older person a higher penalty
yeah and if I remember right it also had
different penalties depending on who you
were higher penalties if you were known
to expect good person
it's kind of a trick question all these
manners right all these are going to be
important for ethical position making
all these are things you have to care
about things you have to look at it in a
situation when you're evaluating what
we're talking about here is evaluation
of the actions patterns of behavior
emotional responses but this is where
Aristotle is kind of unusual this year
is really important if you were a
conscious of dant ologist all that
matter would be the intentions if you
were we're going to look at this theory
later on the semester a utilitarian so
if you're Jeremy Bentham or John Stuart
Mill or the contemporary philosopher
Peter Singer that all the matter would
be the consequences and the only
consequences you with care about pain
and pleasure to to being as a feeling
pleasure
who's doing the action the kind of
character that that person has isn't
really that important the intentions are
important what's important is the
effects right and so there are a lot of
different lot of different ways of
evaluating you have to be able to do
that by the time you get to the end of
the semester so if I were looking at
this like a utilitarian but here's how I
would judge it if I would look like this
and we judge it this way today we're
going to be looking at how you judge
character
the first thing that Excel actually
talks about in this book is how do we
develop care how do we develop good or
bad care and if you think about yourself
at this time all of you are good in some
respects and advantage respects mostly I
mean there could be so many among you
who's completely well integrated
everything totally lined up they have
cultivated all the virtues they have no
vices but in my experience that's
extremely rare I can tell you I'm not
that person myself I have some some
virtuous dispositions with respect to
some things like say courage I also have
some vicious dispositions with respect
to other things like anger I have a
virtuous disposition with respect to
what's called liberality giving and
taking it well I sort of an in-between
disposition when it comes to justice I
do the right thing but I don't always do
it because I want the right thing for
its own sake because I don't want to get
punished because I worry about what
people think that's not yet a virtuous
disposition when it comes to temperance
I would say that I actually have warned
a vicious this position than I do a
virtuous disposition I eat more than I
should
I used to drink more than I should
so I served you know some parts of that
so my own character is in some ways
virtuous and in some ways vicious I've
got some things worked out fairly well
and at the time that I was at your image
I didn't have multiples worked out
I've always been hurt enough courageous
maybe even foolhardy but certainly
didn't have the anger you know as much
under control as I do now never been
temperate life I guess I can actually
say I've not always been this close to
being just as I am and I've got a
prodigal rather than liberal in my my
spending I actually made some bad
decisions so you know if I'm in that
case I wouldn't expect any of you at
your age and your level you know
thinking about this sort of stuff to
have all the virtues down so some of
this is an opportunity think about your
own habits you know virtues or vices or
where you fit in between how do we
become virtuous or vicious
some people think that it's true and
there is something to that strive
because how does practical reasoning
works we have things like during a
situation say
okay I'm in this situation right so
friend tells you I'm going out of town I
want you to walk over my boyfriend or
girlfriend take them out make sure they
have a good time don't let them know
flirt too much with anybody else cetera
etc what's the right they could do in a
situation like that sleep with them
that's a wrong thing all right why don't
you do that students who might be
tempting so in this situation I should
not sleep with the boyfriend/girlfriend
of my my best friend I midnight you know
I'm feeling that temptation
I should resist that that temptation is
knowledge always effective like that and
you can you make people better simply by
saying well here's the rules now follow
them yeah so in some instance that a
repetitive action is a really X is a
nobody is good if it's repetitive like
if you say that right in this situation
I should give him my friend of money
because he needs it
yeah you know at first to be a good
thing but after a while it could lead to
a bad Anu because the person was this
sponging off and not doing getting his
self responsibility through me just say
nah they don't deal with it yourself
yeah what you're talking about is
someone of a higher orders means of
practical reason we've got the
individual action itself right should I
get money at this
than this person and then you've got the
larger the bigger picture higher-order
thing this is a good pattern of
relationship of behavior to to be in
with this person I've needed up that you
know that requires thinking out the
point that I'm trying to get across to
is knowledge by itself it was not always
effective there's you know if you're an
ethics teacher one way that you can make
money is by going into businesses and
doing kind of a song and dance about
others to be ethical because businesses
but I want to show the public that they
can be ethical because there's you know
huge destructs particularly with
corporations business sort of faith in
business has been shaken over the last
two decades and one of the ways to deal
with that is you bring somebody in to
talk about ethics right and then you say
how can we solve it everybody knows
what's right along now
yeah and they're gonna behave they're
gonna behave good we're gonna do the
right things does that actually work not
usually because something else has to be
so it's not just acknowledge its you are
using principles our size
now here's where let's look look at this
this question is what do you do so I'm
going to pick people whatever writing
here has a good skill what are we do
women okay that's interesting what are
you gonna multitasking which is like a
higher again a higher order thing than
you do with the whatever what do you do
that parking yeah I am not good at
partly so I actually can admire I have a
hard time parallel parking now that it
moved to New York and not as fairly
spacious Midwest
sometimes I'll actually like get out of
the car and have my fiancee
what do you film analysis okay okay
what are you either one okay okay
organizing okay these are all pretty
good things to have now for those are
all these things that you guys are
Briggs and those of you who didn't say
you're good
did you just start up automatically be
good at that that's one thing how many
of you have some talent at what you're
doing
I also for micro music's I can generally
pick up an instrument you know how it
works my circuits are walking around
how many of you have to really work at
what you're gonna nothing that you're
good at now swimming even if you would
have to multitask country to good at
multitasking
having too much anymore so you're in
situations where he had to do it my man
assuming was not quite like that but
it's just true you and say did good at
this
how did you get good at practice
what about was how did you yeah that's
that's why I got I got good at cooking
into it one was after my dad died my mom
had to go to work and so then you know
we wanted to eat
you could either what was already heated
up would make something yourself when I
got to college you can either give me
the pay money to other people to make a
good food or you can learn how to make
yourself what else
okay so we've done practice we have game
thrown situations within observation
practice again what else what are other
ways that people got good how did you
get good at partner presenters practice
or healthy spaces yes that's kind of
funny because I have that when it comes
to driving itself like that kind of way
to accidents I have that when it comes
to figuring out what can go to move when
it comes to putting a car in between
other cars
yeah actually writing editing that's
that's a good example you have a couple
different things people critiquing your
writing you got good at writing also
through watch your practice that's one
of the reasons why we make you this your
other professors ought to be doing this
make you write a lot because the only
way you will become a good writer is by
writing while writing a lot of different
kinds of assignments reading other
people's writing is very important too
you can't be a good writer without
reading a lot of other people yeah just
like you know we can't make good films
about watching over
no parking but now swimming and other
athletic things is kind of interesting
to do you swim there's an athlete or is
it just something fun fun those of you
who are athletes in here you guys think
in here your fields you watch films of
other athletes right I don't football
people you guys did it soccer to
basketball why are you doing what are
you getting out of that way it could be
just kind of like watching sports but
that's not your coach you know your
coach is probably gonna tell you pay
attention to this
why yeah it's kind of learn from the
other person's experience of what
they're doing right yeah so you have to
go through a big learning curve of
making all the wrong mistakes yeah is it
always on what they do right your coach
was ever put out don't do this yeah so
you could respond to them Patriots got
themselves with some sort of way that
supposed to do okay so these are now
think about how you would coach another
person because this is a good thing to
think about because all of you are going
to be on initiative you're all in a
major now you're all going to become
practitioners
particular skill or art and probably in
your life you're going to become
practitioners and many persons you know
you're not just going to be business
person or a psychologist or something
like that most would be a parent you're
going to be involved in your community
you're going to be helping other people
to figure out how to cultivate their
talents or if they don't have talent how
to still learn how to do something so if
you can't rely on that hammock talent
what would you do if you want somebody
to learn how to swim what would you
practice right if you want to teach them
how to cook if you wanted to pass on
you've got to your kids what are you
yeah exactly now notice what's going on
here you have habit building and how do
you build have this by actually doing
situations are they going to learn how
to cook while they're swimming probably
not
are you gonna learn how to swim while
they're perfect we're not multitasking
could be a little bit different you
might be combining all these different
things at the same time right
the Aristotle says how do we actually
become just by doing just things in
situations that require justice not
necessarily doing just things in a
loggers watching TV but doing just
things when you're put into the
situation how do you become brave well
by the actual EPA in situations where
it's tough and you do have a feeling of
fear and learning how to deal with your
your fears I'm swimming into this
involves over that doesn't it because
one of our natural fears though that our
body helps is what waterboarding
actually is pretty effective is drowning
you know most animals fear that and
we're no exception
and there there are times like when you
swim long way in underwater and 1.80
conquer the fear of being wanted to
exercise the current virtue of courage
at least within
well how much do we also this goes to
mr. Sato right mr. silos think about if
he had asked it we learned through
models we learned through looking at
other people who have good qualities
where we learned that by looking at
people who have bad qualities the
imitate people we are that's a kind of
creature that we are very limited so if
you possibly surround yourself with
people who are not jaws you're probably
doesn't have to be on jobs it doesn't
mean that you know there's a hundred
percent likelihood that it was
absolutely determined but there's
there's a good chance that you're on
that trajectory so like he says we
become just by doing just acts temperate
by by giving temporary facts to be a
temperate needs to have your pursuit of
bodily pleasures with the control so you
become temperate by actually not having
dessert
you know we'd like to but know that
you're counting your calories those of
you that are there in athletics some of
you mentioned
give the season here in a dry season
you're not allowed to to drink that
requires temperance right that's
developing the works the same way for
for refuse and vices as it does for
scheduling because virtues and vices are
very much like skills
thank says whatever virtue advice of
them so we've gotten that far what are
these things actually
it talks about a few things who talks
about pain and pleasure how can you tell
that somebody really has the virtue
lengths that somebody really is a just
person that they are fair that they
don't take more than their fair share
because of their character and not just
because you're rewarding them or
threatening them and things like that
they feel pleasure in doing it how can
you tell us something really brave they
feel a certain pleasure in standing up
against whatever fears scary things they
do how can you tell somebody's actually
temperance they actually feel pleasure
in turning down certain pleasures that
go too far now if that's why I can say
for instance I'm not actually just
because doing the right thing and I'd
rather do the wrong thing maybe overall
the link right that means that I'm not
yet virtuous with respect to justice if
you're vicious you take pleasure in the
wrong things
so think about anger for example so I'm
not going to ask who's gonna anchor the
problems in here but I'm willing to bet
that at least one third of the class
does give another shooting of American
culture meaning that you get to angry at
the wrong time as the wrong people you
hold onto your anger too long you don't
manage it very well
there's a certain pleasure that's
involved in vicious anger that's why we
hold on to it because we'd get something
out of it it's painful but it's also a
pleasurable at the same time so a
virtuous advice is we can
yeah whether somebody actually feels
pleasure in what they're doing and say
that person is virtuous or not what else
virtue advice are concerned with things
that we choose and things that we avoid
so they're concerned with the whole
spectrum what's good in day habits
that's right wrong
he also says what's pleasant what's not
pleasant what's useful was to our
advantage was to our disadvantage and
then he talks about the noble and this
is something that I want to get out a
little bit because that term is going to
come up over and over again throughout
Aristotle we don't use that term very oh
all right did we talk about anybody
being a noble person what do you think
of when you hear that at that term the
British monarchy or something like that
he doesn't mean that he's contrasting
the the word that he's using in Greek
could mean beautiful or excellent in
some sense or noble or we also translate
it with fine and we oppose it too or the
Honorable in which we transpose it to
the dishonorable the base the ugly all
those sorts of things so it's not just
about good and bad in red nonsense it's
also about the way people seem to us you
all know some people that you can't
stand being around because the way they
behave you just don't like them period
right they kind of disgust you that
would be the opposite of what is called
noble you also have some people that you
like to be around
and you may not be able to put your
finger on exactly why but you admire
them you look up to them help all of you
have something like that right you do
those are that's normal that's what he's
talking about
so virtual advice are concerned with us
those who are virtuous get these things
right those who are vicious get these
things wrong another characteristic that
you can look at to see whether something
is a virtue or advice is does it
actually put the human being into a good
condition to you know be happy people
who are let's take justice and injustice
again people who are jobs number back to
you know book two of the Republic a book
actually book one other diploma -
through senators will the the just
person trying to take advantage of the
other just person no right because their
jobs so they can live together well
they're not going to screw with each
other they're not going steal from each
other they're not going to betray each
other
what about unjust people you guys
probably some of the norms right what is
it all the people the doors just when
you live in the dorms it tends to be
stuff you know confined to stealing and
play music too loud you know you know if
you're playing your music too loud every
night because you like listening to your
music and everybody else should listen
to your music
you're on jostle you're you're being
unfair to be able right I think you had
some experience now you've experienced
so many types of
can hinge up can unjust people live
together well they don't get along with
each other usually and they don't get
along with people who are just they tend
to tick people off who are adjusting
like you know I don't play my music too
loud what the hell's wrong with you
I don't come in at three o'clock in the
morning and kick doors and wake you up
what the hell are you doing that for
right that's a just person or somebody
at least not unjust telling it I'm just
person what to do it very you know easy
to understand kind of situation the
virtues make us able to fulfill our ends
to live together well so becoming
virtuous is is important truth values so
then what is version what is this and
therefore Aristotle
what he's doing is going way beyond
Plato Plato talked about for to advice
right because if you guys wrote about it
in your your third writing aside some of
you you know said I have got this virtue
to this extent I don't have this virtue
and a mess Aristotle is going to give
you much more of a detailed demand of
what futures are so we'll start with
what virtues actually aren't but you
have to deal with our virtues emotions
by themselves like anger or fear no
virtues you have to do is some sort of
subject matter and these can be actions
needs to be emotions needs to be public
limits that we have virtues have to do
itself so courage is not the same thing
as temperance it's not the same thing as
liberality but they all have the same
basic structure one of the insights that
Aristotle hang on this is you know if
there's only one thing that you remember
from this semester with respect to
Aristotle ten years down the line when I
run across you know run into you at the
grocery store or the train station or
you know some other place this is the
one thing I would really like you to
virtue
between access and efficiency it's sort
of like Goldilocks and the three bears
you guys won't remember that story what
did Goldilocks I would settle on what
was what's that what was my hundred she
quit in terms of just just right in this
foam this portraits too hot this courses
at all this is just wrong this bends too
lumpy
asbestos soft this one's just right what
else bad cherish you like broke one
chair I think I don't know where you get
the idea
very few yes that's right so it's going
to be relative to a circle step right
what counts as a temperate meal for me
is going to be a little bit bigger
shouldn't be massively bigger a little
bit thinner then for you know somebody
who's who's smaller most of your smaller
I think Oliver campus class by the way
what counts as courage is going to
depend
situationism I mean there could be some
responses that we write about in this
situation very much in this situation so
it's going to require evaluating once
just right excess is one too much and
efficiency and with any of the virtues
advices that we're going to look at over
the next couple of weeks you can have
too much of something too little or just
right if we take courage for example
courage actually has to do with actions
but it has to do with two kinds of
feelings one is fear you all know that
so if I ask you what courage is you're
probably going to say something like
standing up to your fears it also has to
do with the feeling of confidence which
is the opposite that can be mixed in
with this and courage is when you
actually have the right amount of fear
it doesn't mean having no fear because
you know scary things if they really are
scary things you want to be scared of
them if you're not then you're on the
wrong side here you're not so you're
crazy and there are some people like
that those are sometimes good people
they have like you know a fight or in
water
but often times dollar lot of times they
get you in trouble
they break ranks they they you know
start opening fire too early and they
screw the whole thing up for everybody
that's recklessness or rashes darkness
while our heroes that we see in movies
are actually not courageous they're
reckless if they don't feel any fear
whatsoever there's something wrong with
them something is switched walk inside
the brain of the human psyche the other
half the other side that would be not
having enough confidence that is
cowardice we have a lot of names for
that you know say you're a coward and
say you're a punk
instead we uses what are you gonna say
caller you're probably think about how
we actually use language you don't
actually say you're a coward
that person is a counter yeah what do
you say jaqen yeah chicken yeah you're
yellow all your chicken playground
threads right
well I know what you're thinking up yeah
but this is kind of a good exercise to
do when you're going through hair cells
wear shoes think about how you would
describe it to somebody today
would you call somebody we probably
don't say rash fool-hearty what do you
call somebody who feels no fear when
they want to feel fear and they're
they're constantly getting themselves
into comfortable yeah crazy maybe we
don't do any other words courageous
brave never will be maybe our vocabulary
is not with any of the virtues it's what
you do with that something so I'll give
you another example what he calls
liberality
literally comes from the greek greek
word for being a free person libero
means free not being a slave three of
them
traditional political competition that
we have not other Democratic parties at
all
forget all that stuff for aerosol
liberality has to do with wealth with
your money where your goods or I suppose
it could be with your time and what do
you do with well you give it or spend it
and you take it in right all of you have
any income stream I hope I'll be making
money in one way or another hope so
because you're spending on here right
what happens if you keep spending money
and you don't and you're not taking
money in what's up you go to broke yeah
you can't do things and liberality is
spending the right amount and being
fairly free but with your money not
letting your money dominate you because
we talked about this before what does
the money good for money is good for
other things
if you are actually the kind of person
who is willing to spend money for
friends not in a crazy way but in a you
know a well word way then you're the
liberal person
some people are stingy right they want
to take that they don't want to get some
other people were going to talk about
this more I'm going to get
before they want to get money from any
source whatsoever so though we often say
temp themselves out all right they'll do
just about anything for money that's
advice the person who's in the middle
they do what reason what reason would
say is the best thing to do and they
follow models of people who have those
virtues if you want to figure out
whether your actions are virtuous or
vicious or good or bad for Aristotle you
have to look at what's comprised in the
middle position and you have to look at
other people who act that way hopefully
you have good models I hope all of you
do the models that were presented with
our mixture of good advantage if you
have to act you have more bad models of
good will actually be harder for you to
become virtuous because you'll have to
do a bit of unlearning
so if everybody that you know spends way
too much money and doesn't think about
the consequences and they're always
broke at the end of the month it's going
to be harder for you to see this as the
way that you really want to be is the
way that human beings ought to be
usually do this or if you come from a
family where everybody's a tightwad it's
going to be hard for you to be generous
with your money isn't it because the
models that you have have given you
expectations one of the other things
that Aristotle points out is that this
doesn't always appear to be the best
thing to everybody if you are actually
over here then you are probably going to
see that mental position
being way over here if you are over here
you're going to see that little
positions way over here so if you're
thinking about it in terms of bravery if
you're actually empowered that your
tendency is probably going to be to look
at brave people and say they're really
foolhardy they're crazy they're taking
these huge risk
if you're a fool hearty person and
you're jumping into conflict or whatever
you can you know maybe just for the sake
of glory or something then people who
pick their battles how are you going to
look at them parametric powers they
missed a valuable opportunity to send a
message do something with that
you can think about this in terms of
sports teams right is the team that's
always on the offense the team that wins
this isn't that now and that's where
this action of all scrimmage goes
similar is the team that's always on the
defense that the team can occur based on
the defense right can't score any points
it's got to be a mixture it's got to be
and right amount at the right time for
the right reasons there's a lot of right
skills that have to be determined
now there's there's one other thing that
I want to point out to you
Aristotle recognizes that we may not all
be virtuous or vicious as a matter of
fact most of us are somewhere in between
so this is a way of evaluating people
I'm saying that a person is good or bad
in this respect and you could be
virtuous in one way ambitious enough
another way like for instance I am
virtuous with respect to courage and
they have been for a long time
I am vicious although less vicious
have done before with respect to anger
so I'm good at one way and bad and
another one have work to do
there can be other way other things
where you're not actually virtuous or
vicious your actions can still be good
or bad so generally the actions of the
virtuous person are going to be good
actions general genja generally the
actions of the dish's person will be bad
actions because the characteristic flow
from that person does that mean that the
virtuous person never does any bad
actions they may but it's going to be
very rare what about the vicious person
do they ever do good actions sometimes
probably for the wrong reasons but
sometimes wait what about the rest of
you those those who are in between when
you're looking at actions you could
determine whether an action itself is or
a camera or an emotional response is
virtuous or vicious the person
themselves might not be doing the action
because of their character because
they've established this pattern this
habit
this fabric of their character they may
be sort of on the way one way or the
other
now if they keep doing actions of that
sort they're going to either go off in
this direction and become virtuous or
this direction and become vicious none
of you started out one way or the other
you went one way or the other over time
based on what you've done where are you
going to be ten years from now is going
to be the product of what you choose to
do with you know whatever it is that
you're focusing on for the next ten
years it's going to be based on where
you are right now but you can change
them you know threat that again if I use
myself as an example I realized that I
had a problem thing when
people started tell me a lot of it for
waiters they give some things like
you're a jerk
other things like around you when you
get angry people have different
reactions and I said well I haven't
workout this and so what do you do how
do you actually first you have to
understand your anger management but
then you actually have to get into
situations when you get angry and you
have to change your behavior that's
really tough to do it's one reason why I
haven't made as much progress it's fish
guts right it's very tough to do but if
you want to change your character
that's what it takes you have to break
an old habit and then make a new habit
of how you behave or how you feel or
what you're responsible
it's the same thing with anything else
if you you know again if you want your
kids to learn how to cook you actually
have to bring it into the kitchen and
make them do some of the things help you
make the sauce first you know you don't
you don't start out with a really
difficult okay make me some beef
wellington you start out with the the
fairly easy things baby steps but you're
establishing cannons you're establishing
good I was going to say like by the one
they also have to have the patient yes
because me working with kids yeah
because there's a lot of people that may
want to want to change
and you have to make kid questioning
aerosol dozen this is interesting
aerosol doesn't talk about patients and
as a virtue other people later on will
and what do you think they opposed to
patients with patience is a virtue
but there's going to be some advice
opposed to can you guess what my
tradition has been opposed to patients
anger because when we get a patient with
the people we tend to get angry patients
means basically putting up with other
people's crap and then you know you
could do it for all sorts of reasons
right you put up with people's stuff
because you just can't think the cat
person walks that's not actually real
patients to put out the people's crap
because you feel so bad about yourself
real patients that wouldn't happen
otherwise real patients would be putting
up with other people's nonsense for a
while to the right extent because it's
needed in those sort of situations you
know you're right especially when you're
dealing with kids or also adults it's
very easy to become impatient listen I
can't you awareness well to become
virtuous to whether it's moral virtue or
intellectual virtue or even a physical
virtue like learning how to swim up it
takes a lot of time and practice but you
become virtuous or may become vicious by
doing things over and over again when
you're in those situations that requires
choices to be made that's where we're
going to leave off here because next
class session we're going to look at
this
choice and what's voluntary and what's
involuntary so virtue not only involves
a mean and not only involves what we do
in things how we model things would
involve the choices that we make so have
a good weekend yeah see all of you on
Monday